hello this is a free call from an inmate
at Denver Sheriff's Department County
Jail hi good afternoon how can I help
you everyone who we post bond for is
legally innocent I wonder you if I
qualify the letters come addressed to me
Dear Miss Elizabeth are often full of
really difficult stories three bonds
preventing me from release total
$111,000 I've been arrested take your
hands off of me went to law school of
course I would be directing a bail fund
when I looking at a jail roster and I'm
seeing how many people we got out all I
can really see is how many people are
still in is there any way you guys can
help me I get overwhelmed thinking about
who's not going to be home for Christmas
I saw Elizabeth paying someone's bond
this is the money for this one this one
this one let's start with Miss pain
Liberation is not a zero sum game I get
more free you get okay
[Music]
too